PROFESSOR: We all
regularly drive with a car.
We want to get to from
point A to point B. Usually,
we like to drive with
a constant speed.
But what happens if
there's a traffic light?
Well, we have to
stop eventually,
which means we have to brake.
And that makes the
car decelerate.
So there are different parts
of motion when we ride a car.
It can be constant.
It can be accelerating.
It can be decelerating.
So let's consider this
in a little graphic.
We have a little car here.
And it drives with
constant speed
until someone slams
into the brakes,
and the car will
eventually stop.
Let's add a timeline to this.
Here we're going
to put t equals 0.
The point in time
where the car stops
driving with a
constant speed is t1,
and the point where the car has
come to a complete stop is t2.
And the problem now asks for
what is the position function?
What is the distance at
any kind of time here
as the car goes through these
two different phases of motion?
So ultimately we want
to get to x of t.
But we can't actually
just write this up.
We need to first look
at other information
that we have about
this kind of set up.
And what we have is information
on the acceleration.
And we have to consider
these two phases separately.
So we have here phase
one and phase two.
And phase one is from 0 to t1.
And phase two is from t1 to t2.
And we know when a car is
going with a constant velocity,
it's acceleration
is going to be 0.
So that keeps life
easy for phase one.
And then, when it breaks,
well, we know it decelerates.
So we're definitely going
to have a minus sign.
And it breaks in
between t and t1.
And we need to multiply this
factor here with a constant.
So this is our
acceleration information
that the problem has given us.
And we know, of course, that if
we integrate the acceleration,
we're going to get to
the velocity function.
And if we integrate
that one again,
we're going to get to
our position function.
So let's do that
first for phase one.
And what is also
important here is
that we need to
carefully consider
the initial conditions.
Again, what
additional information
is this problem giving us?
So initial conditions-- they
always make life a lot easier.
So it's important to
carefully look for them.
And what that means
is we want to know
what the distance
is at t equal 0,
and what the velocity
at time 0 is.
And we know the
distance here is 0.
And we know that the problem
starts when the car is already
driving with a constant speed.
So that's going to be v not.
So let's then make
use of this, and start
integrating our acceleration.
We want to get to
the velocities.
So v of t minus of t equals 0
is going to be that integral.
And here already we know that we
have v of t equals 0 is v not.
So this already
looks pretty nice.
And now we have our
integral here of a.
And of course, now t is
an integration variable.
So we have to give this a prime.
And we're integrating
from t prime equals 0
to t prime equals t.
And when we plug
this in, well, a
is 0 in phase one,
which means actually,
our integral is going to be 0.
That's handy.
And from that, we will find
that v of t equals simply v not.
All good.
Now we need to integrate this
to get to our position function.
Same thing again-- x of t
minus x of t equals zero.
Let's quickly check here what
we know about x of t is 0.
Well, it's 0 from the
initial conditions.
And now we have to integrate
our velocity function here,
v not dt, again, prime.
t prime equals 0.
t prime equals t.
These are our boundaries.
And this is simply going to
be v not t prime evaluated
from 0 to t.
And we can add that--
we can add that in there.
And it's just going to be vt.
So x of t--
I can just write it here
again, x of t equals v not t.
OK.
Good.
So half of the question is--
half of the problem is solved.
Let's look at the same
things for phase two.
So let's consider the initial
conditions for phase two now.
And again, now we want to--
in an analogous way--
look at the distance
of what we know about
the distance at t1
and the velocity at t1.
And about the position,
we know from over there
that this is v not t.
So our previous result
now actually becomes
the initial condition
for the next step, right?
Because whatever
happens here sets
whatever happens afterwards.
So that's nice.
And we know that, up
to this moment here,
this car goes with
the velocity of v not.